for 30 days straight I scoured the
entire internet for the best one piece
fun facts and secrets I could find I
went through each Q&A Oda did scrolled
through countless Reddit posts and even
included some I noticed myself there are
a total of 91 Secrets I found and I
guarantee you didn't know some of these
for example you all know how big mom's
goal was to have as many children as
possible and also have at least one of
every race in order to achieve this she
obviously needed many different husbands
but but did you ever wonder how exactly
does she find them I mean she isn't
really the prettiest pirate on the Seas
well as you would guess big mom doesn't
play nice and as soon as she sees
someone whom she wants to have a child
with she just kidnaps them oh also after
giving birth she immediately kicks the
husband out forbidding him from ever
seeing his children but out of all of
big mom's children I never want to find
myself near this one Juku devil fruit
allows him to rub his stomach to summon
a genie fighter however if he does it
too many times instead of a genie a
giant fart will come out instead H I
guess it's one of the drawbacks of being
the minister of beans I'm guessing most
of you already know that all of the
Admirals are named after a color and an
animal for example Aku means Red Dog
kizaru means yellow monkey and so on but
have you ever stopped to think who
actually gave them these nicknames well
for some reason the Marines have a whole
division dedicated to assigning epithets
to their Fighters the head of this
division is nazu kagari whose name
literally translates to wants to name
and we can't talk about fun facts
without mentioning the legendary
nicknames Luffy gives to characters some
of those are pigeon guy cabbage and
pineapple but did you ever notice that
even though he gives a nickname to every
person he meets he never gave any
nicknames to his crew mates the reason
for this is very simple you see Luffy
only gives nicknames to people because
he doesn't care about them enough to
learn their real names but when they
become a part of the crew he will make
sure to remember and use their real
names so you know how nami's dream is to
draw a map of the entire world but how
exactly does she plan to do this does
she plan to remember all of the places
she's been to and then draw it from
memory well of course not that would be
impossible although we rarely see her
draw on the show Oda actually revealed
that every day after dinner Nami draws a
map of the area they sailed through that
day without ever missing a day Chopper
mentioned a few times how he is not
attracted to humans since he wasn't
originally a human but reindeer due to
this many thought he would never find
true love as there were no other
reindeer like him but then we were
introduced to milky on zoo a reindeer
mink Chopper quickly fell in love with
her and she became the only person in
the world he wanted to date after
defeating doflamingo andr Rosa many
Straw Hat members bounties were raised
by 50 million berries even though some
of them didn't even participate in the
fight the reason behind this is that the
Marines can't exactly tell who fought
who and translate it to numbers well so
they just add a flat amount to
everyone's Bounty this happened again
when most of the straw hats bounties
jumped by 300 million berries following
the raid on onigashima most of you
probably noticed how the Sea restaurant
Bara got much bigger over time we can
clearly see how bigger it is in chapter
92 however the thing most of you didn't
know about is that two more barate
restaurants have been opened since Sanji
left the first one is run by Patty and
is an underwater restaurant while the
second one is run by KS and looks a lot
like the original barate except it has a
giant Sanji head in the front huh looks
like sanji's popularity as a pirate
really boosted the business I don't know
about you guys but I always wondered
what are these crackling things at the
tips of sweet Commander Cracker's hair
well in one of the SBS Oda was asked
this exact question and his answer is
ridiculous as it turns out when creating
the character Oda had absolutely no idea
what these crackling things were himself
but he kept them because he thought they
looked cool the first time sanji's
Bounty was in issued his Bounty photo
was actually a drawing instead of a
photo did you ever wonder why that is
well this happened because a certain
someone forgot to remove the cap from
the camera when taking sanji's photo
that someone is attached who was the
head of the Marine's photography
department but was fired after
forgetting to remove the cap from his
camera on 56 other occasions but I
guarantee almost none of you noticed
this little change Oda made you see at
the beginning of the show we saw Shanks
and his crew drink alcohol from beer
mugs same as many other Pirates
throughout early one piece however
sometime later everyone started drinking
from these Barrel looking mugs instead
Odo revealed that he actually made this
change because he didn't want to imply
that it was alcohol everyone was
drinking since not all the characters
are of drinking age which is 20 in Japan
but we can also agree that Barrel mugs
look much cooler than the regular ones
so you all remember Nama land an in
between floor in impel down where bonov
led the prisoners but did you ever
wonder how was this space created and
why don't the prison guards know about
him well you see before he joined the
Revolutionary Army mlay the commander of
the West Division was a nasty pirate at
some point due to his actions he was
imprisoned and impelled down but escaped
using his devil fruit that allows him to
freely manipulate the ground many many
years later ivankov found this empty
space by accident and turned it into
Nama land oh also despite both mlay and
ivankov being high-ranking officials of
the Revolutionary Army ivankov still
doesn't know that mlay is the one who
dug up that space all the way back back
in chapter 1 when Bandit Kuma kicked
down the bar's door something weird
happened see just a few pages later that
same door was magically fixed how the
heck did that happen well while
answering fans questions Odo revealed
that it was fixed by a character called
matomo he's this short grumpy looking
guy who just can't resist fixing broken
stuff when he sees them Jokes Aside it's
obvious that Oda just forgot to draw a
broken door so he came up with this
ridiculous explanation for it throughout
the show we saw a few times that
inanimate objects can also eat devil
fruits some examples are spandam sword
which ate elephant elephant fruit and Mr
for's bazooka which ate doxen fruit
although we don't know how these objects
even ate devil fruits there is another
example of this that most of you
probably missed in Suki yaki's house in
wano if you look closely you can see a
teapot that looks alive this guy's name
is Bambu and it ate the Inu Inu Nomi
model Tanuki turning it into a live
Tanuki however since it's now alive and
can feel stuff it can't be used to heat
up tea anymore because hot tea will burn
it the transponder snails are weird
creatures with a weird ability they
pretty much work like phones but can
also mimic the appearance of anyone who
is speaking through them however the
most interesting thing about them is
that unlike phones they are living
beings and have emotions so if a
transponder snail is sleepy or hungry it
might not want to use its mimicking
abilities let's Now cover a fact that
only manga readers know if you ever read
one piece you probably notice these
cover panels at the beginning of each
chapter well when you combine these
panels throughout multiple chapters
you'll actually get a whole mini story
however the most interesting thing is
that the characters appearing in these
Min stories usually make an appearance
in the main story later on for example
in this cover story after the citizens
of lulua threw Ace into the river he was
saved by Moda a girl selling milk
several hundred chapters later when
Peach beard attacked lulua it was none
other than Moda who defeated him did you
ever want to know the backstory of this
frog that was chilling on usopp's head
while he worked as a toad oil salesman
probably not but here it is anyway his
name is GMA Pinos and one day while he
was chilling he saw a snake he got
scared and jumped on the first person he
saw to get away from danger which
happened to be Usopp and it's good he
landed on Usopp because the moment Usopp
saw the snake he ran away at full speed
yoske then decided to stay on usopp's
head to avoid any more dangerous
situations many people compared D
Flamingo to Spider-Man mainly because of
their web slinging abilities but also
because doflamingo's glasses resemble
Spider-Man's eyes a lot however when Oda
was asked about this he said that
Spider-Man wasn't that popular in Japan
until recently and he actually took
inspiration from a completely different
character that character is common riter
super one and you can clearly see a
resemblance when it comes to their eyes
you probably noticed how everyone who
has eaten the devil fruit said that it
tastes awful however when Momos ate it
he wasn't really bothered by it and the
people of IBU even called it delicious
this is because they've all eaten the
smile devil fruits with Caesar managed
to modify in order to get rid of the bad
taste real devil fruits have they now
taste just like normal fruit due to one
piece having thousands and thousands of
characters Oda often takes inspiration
when designing them some of those
Inspirations include Admirals who are
all based on famous Japanese actors but
there are also some lesser known ones
for example shinobu a retainer of the
Kazuki family was actually created to
look like the famous Japanese comedian
Naomi wanabi although KATU looks like a
Kaa mainly because of his green colored
skin and Beak looking mouth he is in
fact not because Kaa don't exist in the
world of one piece but if he isn't a
Coppa what is he well KATU is actually a
tiger puffer fish man the reason he acts
like a cppa is because his mother told
him to do so so he wouldn't be
discriminated against by humans for
being a fish man throughout the show we
saw a few characters who had abnormally
large heads naturally when seeing a
bunch of big heads you will ask the
question whose head is the biggest well
firstly since Vega Punk shortened his
head he is disqualified but otherwise he
would be the Victor not counting him the
character with the biggest head in the
entire one piece is vice admiral
strawberry whose head grows even more
every time he gets sad big heads are
cool but you know what's even cooler Pig
NOS it so who do you think has the
biggest nose in the entire one piece
maybe Usopp well you'll be surprised to
hear that while usopp's nose is 13 cm
long it's only the fourth longest nose
in the show both Katarina Devon and
arlong have long longer noses than Usopp
while the person with the absolute
longest nose is the Titanic captain
Vasco shot seems like Usopp has a lot
more lying to do if he plans on becoming
the number one but Oda hit a little
secret in Chapter 977 that I'm honestly
surprised anyone has managed to find it
literally took me 10 minutes to find it
and I was purposely looking for it this
chapter starts off with nami and a few
other straw hats hugging jimbe and on
the next page hidden in the corner you
can see little Sanji biting a
handkerchief out of sadness and jealousy
another tiny yet significant detail was
hidden near the end of sanji's battle
against Queen if you ever paid attention
you probably noticed that the eyebrows
of sanji's siblings look like 66 while
Sanji were always inverted since he
didn't awaken the powers they did
however when he finally awakened his
abilities his eyebrows reversed to look
like 66 as well after the battle had
been concluded sanji's eyebrows had gone
back to normal meaning he can switch his
germa abilities on and off he confirmed
this in his fight against es shark when
his eyebrows reversed again and suddenly
es shark couldn't touch him although you
probably noticed that king queen and
Jack of the Beast Pirates are named
after playing cards I bet you didn't
know this you see although it's less
obvious the flying six are also named
after card games suzaki black Maria and
Alti are all games you can play with
cards but that's not all because every
headliner is also named after card games
like hold them solitire and poker but
that's still not all because some of the
numbers are also named after card games
wow this is pretty interesting let's now
reveal something all of you wanted to
know at one point which devil fruits
would the straw hats who don't already
have one pick if they had a chance well
according to Oda Zoro would choose
kaido's uomi model seru but he wouldn't
actually eat it he would give it to one
of his swords Nami would pick anel's
Goro goromi because it goes well with
her fighting style and abilities Uso
would eat the poke poke no me because
infinite Pockets means he can can
prepare an infinite amount of Tricks
Sanji would take Senor pink su su Nomi
because well because I don't know why
honestly and lastly Frankie would
obviously take baby F's boyboy gomi
because the only thing he wants is more
weapons okay you all know how anime
characters always have the same hair
throughout the show without it ever
growing well one piece is different
because everyone on the crew grows hair
it's just that three crew mates give
everyone frequent haircuts so to us it
doesn't look like anything changes the
three hair cutters of the crew are USA
Sanji and Robin in chapter 963 the
mountain God Yama is shown to be alive
even though a few chapters back Odin
sliced it in half the explanation for
this is quite simple but also quite
weird you see when Odin cut the mountain
God his cut was so clean yama's body
could easily be put back together no one
else was yet seen doing something like
this which just goes to show how
insanely strong Odin was we already said
how Oda loves to take inspiration from
other media when designing his
characters however sometimes he also
takes inspiration when drawing specific
panels for example when he visited Kyoto
Odo went to the kinji temple where he
saw the picture of two dragons he
instantly thought he had to draw this
and he later did when MOS confronted
kaido on the rooftop but did you ever
wonder how Captain kid became a pirate
you see he killer wire and heat were all
leaders of rivaling gangs in the South
Blue although they were Rivals they were
also friends and they respected each
other one day the Island's strongest
gang killed kid's childhood friend
Victoria which made him so mad he teamed
up with his Rivals and together they
defeated the gang avenging Victoria
after that kid decided he didn't want to
stay on some small island for the rest
of his life so he became a pirate
together with his friends so do you
remember how I said that all Admirals
were named after a color and an animal
well as it turns out there's actually
another character besides them whose
name also follows this rule this
character is Koma the director of the
Marines criminal investigative service
whose name literally translates to Black
Horse but that's not the only thing
connecting him to the Admirals as same
as the rest of them he is also modeled
after the real life actor Akira
Kobayashi does this mean that kuroma
will become the next Admiral in the
future who knows however one thing we do
know is that every Marine has a certain
type of Justice they follow it's kind of
like a rule that determines what's good
and what's not for example so far in the
show we've seen absolute Justice
uncertain Justice and even lazy Justice
many were curious about which Justice to
the two new Admirals follow and Oda gave
us the answer Admiral greenbull supports
so-called determined Justice which is
really similar to Absolute Justice while
Fuji Torah follows Humane Justice which
means that he puts protecting the
innocent above chasing criminals
recently on Egghead we were finally
introduced to Dr Vega Punk and his six
satellites while examining one of them
Pythagoras one fan noticed something
interesting Pythagoras design really
reminded him of one of the characters
from the show they used to watch called
gambari robocon and if we compare the
two we can see that they look almost
identical Oda actually responded to this
confirming that he took inspiration from
robocon as he really liked watching the
show over 40 years ago when he was a kid
but there is even more stuff in oda's
childhood that inspired him for example
when cp9 members arrive at their
Hometown where all future CP members are
trained we can see this Tower which
looks exactly like this Chinese temple
in wzu Otis said he wanted the cp9
training ground to be Chinese oriented
because he grew up with a lot of kung fu
movies
however as you can already guess the
references don't stop there as Luffy's
signature gear forth position is also
inspired by something in the real world
this specific pose resembles a Neo
statue that can be found guarding
Buddhist temples these statues symbolize
power and if I had one word to describe
gear 4 it would definitely be powerful
during big mom's backstory we saw two
young Giants hodin and his friend now we
all know who hodin grew up to be but
what if I tell you that we also saw this
friend of his much earlier in the show
you see this giant is none other than
stansen the giant who was imprisoned at
the auction house on somebody during
that time he said that if he ever met
the straw hats again he would pay them
back and that's exactly what he's doing
because he's a member of the new giant
Pirates Who are a part of the straw hat
Grand Fleet okay these connections maybe
weren't that hard to make but what about
big mom's childhood friend gerd do you
know who she grew up to be well she
became a doctor of the new giant Pirates
and you can clearly see her in this
scene we can also see her again in Vega
Punk's backstory with the other Giants
collecting all the books that were left
on Ohara while being imprisoned and
impelled down doflamingo asked suru if
he could get newspapers to read because
he was bored and she obviously declined
since she had absolutely no reason to
listen to him so what was do Flamingo
doing the next time we saw him reading a
newspaper many people thought that suru
eventually felt sorry and gave it to him
but that's not what happened the reason
he got them is because he knows many
people people in prison due to being one
of the most influential criminals so it
shouldn't be surprising that he gets his
hands on the newspaper from time to time
but did you ever stop to question how
does zunesha stand in the middle of the
ocean I mean it's enormous but still
this shouldn't be possible well someone
asked Oda this exact question and he
replied that zunesha is not a normal
elephant but a nitami Norita elephant a
species that has oversized legs with
multiple joints considering that Zuna is
around 35 km tall it's legs have to be
at least 30 km although we've seen
multiple Sky Islands throughout the show
the sky island balloon terminal in the
new world is unlike any other the main
difference is that this island is not
just floating in the air it's actually
being held up by thousands of helium
balloons but how did these balloons even
end up there well you see these balloons
actually come from all those unlucky
children who accidentally let go of
their balloons in law's backstory when
he attacks corazone if you look really
closely you can see crocodile's face in
the newspaper so what was this article
about well during that time crocodile
was quickly becoming famous for doing a
lot of crazy stuff but after his
devastating loss against Whitebeard he
decided to go back to alabasta and start
plotting his plan to take over the
country the specific news article
Corazon was reading commented on how
heroic and nice crocodile is for
defending the people of alabasta from
Pirates during the Marine Fort War we've
seen just how big whitebeard's crew was
however if you paid close attention
during this time you probably notice
that despite these few nurses there
isn't a single female on This Crew this
is because Whitebeard believed that
women shouldn't be Fighters and that's
why he left his entire medical team in a
safe place before he went to Marine Ford
oh and if you think you remember seeing
a woman on the whitebeard's crew during
the summit war that was just U it's no
secret that there are many emotional
scenes in one piece but did you know
that Oda often gets emotional himself
when drawing he even said that sometimes
he would tear up and need to take a
short break before coming back to finish
the drawing and if you're wondering
which scene made him cry the most it's
this exact scene where vivv is screaming
for her people to stop killing each
other but no one can hear her this next
little secret was not even found by fans
it was instead found by one of the fans
parents you see same as all other
Admirals fujitora's design is also based
on a Japanese actor however this one was
popular almost 50 years ago meaning many
younger fans would have no way of
knowing who he is this actor is called
shintu KATU and not only does he look
the same as Fuji Tor but he also played
the role of a blind swordsman at one
point so far in the video we learned
that it's a kid Oda liked Japanese
movies Kung Fu and comedy shows so what
else did he like how about wrestling on
Dr Rosa we were introduced to two former
bounty hunters Abdullah and Jet those
names are a clear reference to two
retired pro wrestlers Abdullah the
Butcher and tiger jet sing Oda used to
watch these two a lot when he was in
elementary school and wanted to draw
them in the manga but did you know that
absum of Thriller bark Pirates became a
reporter sometime after he was defeated
by the straw hats on one of the pages in
chapter 700 we can see a thriller bark
ship sailing while kid is talking about
the mysterious Absa which is of course
absolum the job of a reporter was really
easy for him due to his invisibility
devil fruit and he often spied on kids
aoo and Hawkins Alliance his articles
became really popular in the new world
but sadly I doubt any more will come out
after he left the Marines Kuan found
himself a cute companion and no I'm not
talking about Blackbeard but camel camel
is a penguin that accompanies Kuan
wherever he goes he's 5 m tall and
that's because he is a super penguin a
species that is much bigger than normal
penguins and is also very good at
staying above water camel can even keep
himself from sinking without moving at
all those of you who have been following
one piece for some time probably heard
about a short story Oda created a while
back called monsters it's a story about
a samurai called ryuma and how he slayed
a dragon it's no secret that rayuma
served as an inspiration for creating
Zoro but did you know that rayuma also
inspired another scene in the manga
remember a scene from Punk Hazard when
Zoro cut the dragon's head now look at
this panel of ryuma killing a dragon
they're pretty much the same it's a very
nice reference to oda's work from almost
three decades ago but can you guess what
real life person was oda's inspiration
for Sanji when asked this question most
people answer Leonardo Dicaprio and
although this is a pretty good guess
it's not correct Sanji is actually based
on Steve busi from the movie Reservoir
Dogs before publicly revealing this Oda
said that only one person he knew
correctly guessed it okay we covered a
lot of small details but this one may
just be the teeniest detail we ever
covered in chapter 653 Zoro and Sanji
are fighting as usual and Sanji tells
him that he shouldn't be messed with
because he can put anything he wants
into zoro's food however Zoro is not
afraid of this and tells him that he can
even eat poison and razor blades if
needed most of you probably just forgot
this conversation soon after but Sanji
didn't you see just two chapters later
Sanji prepared lunch boxes for everyone
and if you look closely you can see that
Zoro is really struggling this is
because Sanji actually put razor blades
in his lunchbox which you can also tell
by the hard crunch crunch sound effect
so you all know how the majority of the
things Usopp makes up end up being true
well Luffy once did something similar
all the way back in East blue in chapter
69 nice Sanji and yosaku talk about
fishmen and mermaids while Luffy draws a
few pictures trying to guess what they
looked like he eventually ended up with
this weird drawing which just looked
like a fish with arms and legs however
557 chapters later on this exact page
far in the crowd we can see this exact
creature in 2010 Odo released a data
book called One Piece green where he
shared a lot of early sketches of
characters that he wanted to introduced
to the story at some point the thing
that caught everyone's attention was
that the Blackbeard Pirates were
supposed to have a beautiful swordswoman
from wano on their team however this
character was eventually scraped off to
make space for Katarina Devon which is
well a significant downgrade when asked
about this Odus stated that he changed
the Blackbeard Pirates design many many
times because he wanted to make sure
they all looked perfect and he just
didn't see a pretty character fitting
into a crew full of ugly and dirty
Pirates one of the saddest places in the
entire show has to be the great terminal
this junkyard is a lawless area where
most people die due to sickness air
pollution well believe it or not this
place is actually based on a real
location called Smoky Mountain located
in the Philippines right next to its
capital Manila same as how the gray
terminal is right next to the rich Goa
Kingdom one fan was really curious about
how Inazuma came out of ivanov's hair in
this one scene so he asked Oda If people
could pay Ivanov to live in her hair
like a hotel and they can but it'll cost
them if you want to stay for one night
it'll cost 5,000 berries but if ionov is
traveling over the ocean you'll only
need to pay extra for the ocean view if
you have a bit more money on you you
could even rent out the big comfortable
room in aov's Crown too although Boa
Hancock was first introduced in chapter
516 what if I tell you that we saw her
way before that you see after the L Town
Arc Odo was asked to draw a few
characters straw hats will encounter
when they enter the grand line and if
you take a closer look you'll notice
that one of these characters is Boa
Hancock although her design ended up
being a bit different when she was
officially introduced remember clal man
it's the spirit of a ship that can
manifest when the ship is loved and
cared for whoop saw it on the sky island
when the spirit appeared to repair going
marry if it wasn't obvious from its name
the story about these Spirits originates
from Germany and German Sailors who
believed that the spirit was the ship's
guardian and would ensure they traveled
safely everyone knows that devil fruit
users and water don't go well together
so have you ever wondered how do devil
fruit users take a shower you see devil
fruit users are hated by the Sea so if
they get submerged in a big body of
Still Water they'll grow we weak but any
moving water like raindrops will not
affect them so as far as showers go as
long as they stand up and don't let too
much of their body be submerged in water
they'll be fine the only exception to
this rule is crocodile whose abilities
will be fully nullified even while
showering due to him being made out of
sand but you'd be surprised to find out
just how much research Oda does before
naming stuff in the one piece World take
sea trains from water 7 as an example
the puffing Tom is named after the
puffing Billy which is the oldest
locomotive train in the the world that's
been transporting people for over 200
years the Rocket Man was named after
Stevenson's rocket which was built to
prove that locomotives were better than
stationary steam engines also the man
who built the first steam engine was
called Thomas so that could be where Oda
got the inspiration for the famous
shipright Tom okay you all know that
when Luffy gets near the fridge the
whole crew May starve this already
happened a few times throughout the show
well that's why Sunny's fridge now has a
special password Luffy doesn't know the
password for the lock is genius it's 73
26 because s and three stand for Nami
three and two stand for S G and two and
six stand for n Ro and only these three
know the password but did you know that
the straw hats were originally supposed
to be really different for example Robin
was supposed to be this botnus guy on
the left and Chopper was supposed to be
this weird reindeer swordsman that's not
all because Oda initially planned on
making Nami with robotic Limbs and a
huge axe while Sanji was supposed to be
a cowboy wielding dual pistols so a lot
of One Piece fans love to believe that
Oda has every single detail planned out
beforehand and that he knows exactly how
the story will develop but is this
really true well it looks like he has
most of the stuff figured out but he
keeps adding non-planned stuff in
between for example the supernovas were
a last minute addition and Odin never
planned on introducing them at all and
just look how important they are now law
has been with the crew since the time
skip kid helped with taking down big mom
and in the current Arc Bonnie is really
important but super noas aren't the only
thing Oda added last minute and there's
another group of characters that he
didn't plan on including at all you see
the story of One Piece was always meant
to focus on taking down the Emperors but
then Oda added the Warlords of the sea
and slowed down the story by hundreds of
chapters three of these Warlords even
have their own arcs many of them are
still very important to the plot of the
story I guess even a genius like Oda
doesn't have it all planned out there's
an ongoing joke in the phandom that
because one piece has gone on for so
many years it may outlive Oda himself
self now although this is very unlikely
to happen since Oda isn't that old one
person who is actually scared of not
being there to witness the end of one
piece is Luffy's voice actor mayumi
Tanaka who is 68 years old but don't
worry because if that happens her son
commented that masaku naawa the voice of
Goku will take her place but there's a
problem Goku's voice actor is actually
over 20 years older than Luffy's so I'm
not really sure how that's supposed to
work now it's common knowledge that the
One Piece manga often changes some minor
stuff like small mistakes for example
before printing the final volumes
however this one time they had to change
something a lot bigger you see after
AC's introduction we got to see the
Jolly Roger of the Whitebeard pirates
for the first time yeah let's just say
that the original symbol on the flag
wasn't really appropriate for most of
the world now in Japan this symbol
represents benevolence and good fortune
but due to how it's perceived in most of
the world this was quickly changed to
the new flag we know today but what
about a fun question next do you know
who's the only only Straw Hat who has
never met any of Luffy's Brothers it
can't be the East blue crew and Chopper
since they met Ace on alabasta it also
can't be Robin or Frankie since they met
Sabo on dress Rosa and it obviously
can't be jinbe since he's known Ace for
a long time that only leaves Brooke who
never had the chance to meet Ace and
also missed his chance to meet Sabo
since he left Russ Rosa early we all
love one piece figurines and merchandise
but there was one time when a few people
brought it to the next level around 14
years ago news broke that real pirates
yes they exist hijacked a ship and even
put up a pirate flag on it and their
choice for the flag the redhair pirate
flag maybe they're trying to tell us
that they are good pirates in one of the
SPs Oda Drew how the straw hats would
look like when they turned 40 and 60
years old but what's more interesting is
that he included a timeline where
something went wrong where everyone just
looked awful they all look out of shape
and broke Chopper becomes something like
a Mafia Boss Nami becomes a scam artist
and Sanji actually looks like his father
huh that's hope the straw hats don't end
up in this timeline for real throughout
the story Zoro earned a few scars that
have been with him ever since like the
one on his chest that he got from
fighting mihawk or the mysterious scar
in his eye he got sometime during the
time skip however Zoro has another
notable scar that almost everyone forgot
it's the scar from when he almost cut
his legs during the fight against Mr 3
these scars on his ankles are still with
him to this day though they're very
inconsistent as both Manga and Anime
often forget about them the recently
finished wano country Arc lasted for
about 2 weeks in real time from when
Luffy came to the island to kaido's
defeat now that's a long time for the
straw hats to be on one Island so it's
understandable that this is the longest
Arc in the series but what doesn't make
sense is that the second longest Arc is
dress Rosa you see this Arc lasted for
102 chapters however the events in real
time happened in only a few hours after
the battle the crew stayed on dress Rosa
for 3 Days To recover so they literally
slept more than they F even if it's a
pretty logical name the first time Luffy
got called Straw Hat Luffy is when naumi
asked for a bounty to be put up on his
head in chapter 94 however the straw hat
Pirates weren't named that for a long
time the first person to call them the
straw hat Pirates is none other than
smoker all the way in alabasta from our
perspective the straw hats have been
together for over 20 years but in
reality it took them just 7 months to
reach sabot and after the time Skip it's
only been two more months this means
that Luffy has been with rley longer
than he has been with his crew the same
goes for Zoro and mihawk and Robin and
dragon oh also remember that touching
reunion between Kobe and Luffy on water
7 well in one piece World it hasn't even
been 3 months since they last saw each
other big mom gave birth to her first
child when she was 18 and she had her
last child when she was 60 based on this
we can calculate that she gave birth to
her 855 children in only 42 years that's
two births a year this means that she
was somehow constantly pregnant this
would mean that big mom fought as one of
the Rocks Pirates while pregnant and
that she later became an Emperor as a
pregnant woman pretty interesting do you
know which Straw Hat has the most screen
time after Luffy it it has to be Zoro
right if not then it absolutely has to
be Sanji well it's neither of them and
it's actually Nami this is a really
surprising fact considering she was
absent for almost the entirety of dress
Rosa in Orangetown after Luffy and the
others defeated buggy he was left there
Limbs and couldn't immediately go back
to his crew in the meantime his crew
members who thought he had died decided
they needed a new captain Moji and
kabaji fight to see who is worthy of
being a new captain but Richie the lion
accidentally defeats both of them in his
sleep becoming the captain of the Richie
Pirates sadly the Richie Pirates didn't
last for a single cover page because
they were instantly defeated by a nearby
tribe now we all know that Dr Vega Punk
is the world's best scientist and Caesar
Clown is the close second however the
difference between them may be much
bigger than you think during the dress
Rosa Arc we learned that only one in 10
smiles grow normally and then those
normal spiles only have a 10% chance to
actually work using some advanced math
we can deduce that the success rate of
smiles is only 1% this means that even
with kaido and doflamingo's backing
Caesar couldn't figure out a way to do
it on the other hand Vega Punk has
managed to replicate multiple existing
paramia devil fruits which just goes to
show how far ahead of Caesar he is in
both technology and knowledge so you
remember this scene when Viv met Leo and
the other tentas during the levely arc
during the whole conversation Karu was
just standing there staring at Leo
almost as if he was mad at him or
something so what could it be maybe he
didn't like Leo as a pirate well as it
turns out the thing that made Karu so
mad is that Vivi called Leo cute Oda
likes to make his characters feel more
real by telling us what their favorite
dish is or what they like to do in their
spare time so he gave every
revolutionary officer a favorite food
and hobby starting with karasu his hobby
is volunteering and his favorite food is
wieners Berg's hobby is playing board
games and his favorite food is
hamburgers for Bellow Betty it's
gardening and almonds and for moay it's
karaoke and bagnata which is some sort
of soup made from garlic and fish but
very few people know that Oda actually
made a few versions of One Piece before
he was satisfied in one of the versions
the one who inspired Luffy to become a
pirate and gave him his iconic Straw Hat
was gar in another version Luffy never
meets Nami instead he meets a similar
character called shuku and together they
beat the Crescent Moon galy what's funny
is that g is a confirmed Canon character
as he appeared in barate in chapter 92
waiting to get his food at one point Odo
was challenged to bring zoro's three
swords vad ichimonji son dait tetu and
shishui to life and draw them as people
he outdid himself with these three
drawings and Dre the three ugliest
characters ever but hey at least they
sort of look like people you would find
on wano similarly to what he did with
the Revolutionary officers Odo wanted us
to know the commanders of the straw hat
Grand Fleet a bit better so he told us
what food each of them loves and hates
Cavendish likes to eat roses and he
would never eat something basic like
Ramen bartalo obviously likes sweets and
hates vegetables like the child he is
while donai will eat anything baby five
makes for him and for all others you can
pause the video right here hibari is
another sword member we haven't really
seen that much though there's some
information about our back story that
almost no one knows when she was little
hibari always kept her teddy bear with
her as a good luck charm but one time
when something went wrong on the
battlefield she lost it when Kobe heard
of this he rushed back to the
battlefield and ended up very injured
but he got tiari her teddy bear back I'm
pretty sure she fell in love with him
after that although some Pirates have
obvious Hobbies like drinking and
adventuring some of them have more
unique ones for example law likes
collecting commemorative coins Kid Likes
listening to music killer likes to play
drums and cook halap poo likes to DJ and
surf b is a boring old guy so he likes
to view paintings and play board games
while exr likes to study astrophysics
Bonnie likes to eat and play D Jenga no
surprises there while Blackbeard loves
to gamble and research history and the
most shocking of all uday's hobbies are
drinking traveling and love making huh
interesting but I bet you didn't know
about this mysterious rivalry when
Shanks came to Marine Ford to end the
war his crewmate yosup had an intense
staring contest with whitebeard's fifth
division Commander Vista even though
this is a small detail many people
noticed it and qu quickly went to ask
Oda about it he confirmed that the two
have some sort of rivalry but didn't
elaborate further this next fun fact is
really well known but it's still worth
mentioning since it's really interesting
you see in the story of One Piece there
are literally thousands of pirates but
for some reason no pirate ever wears an
eye patch this is pretty weird because
the first thing you think about when you
hear the word eye patch is Pirates
however for Oda an eye patch is the
ultimate symbol of a pirate so he won't
just easily give it to someone that's
why he said that one very special
character will get an eye patch near the
end of the story considering it's one
piece I hope we get to see this
character by the end of the decade
smoker tashigi and Hina also have their
Hobbies revealed Smoker's hobbies are
making ceramic art and gambling very
irresponsible for a marine officer
tashiki likes to read books about swords
and create kir which is something
similar to origami however Hina has the
most interesting ones as she likes
riding horses and going to clubs also
did you know that smoker and Hina are
basically confirmed as a couple we even
saw them on a date on one of the cover
stories and their left hands are always
hidden almost as if Oda is hiding their
Rings okay I think that's quite enough
facts for today but I got a question do
you also like theories if the answer is
yes click on this video next where we
explain the entire one piece Theory
iceberg